and now we are also joined with uh
magnus carlsen after a great fight in
the final again magnus
losing to wesley so how are you feeling
after this
um i'm a bit frustrated
uh today um obviously losing
losing is uh is okay
uh to wesley um he he clearly had the
most
convincing tournament coming coming up
to
today um but i do feel
as as though i uh i missed quite a lot
of
chances uh today uh and uh
that's the that's the frustrating part
um
particularly that at several points i
did not
trust my my intuition and i i sort of
trusted him
him more there because he was playing so
quickly and confidently that i couldn't
really um get myself to believe that he
was
missing a lot of things um
mainly in the third game i mean um
so uh yeah i really really should have
taken
my chances there and uh also
the the fourth game where um
um i sort of i could
definitely feel after the opening that
my position was
was uh winning and it would only take
um a few
um few um uh sort of um
accurate moves to win um
and the uh yeah the
the especially one moment there
uh was i think we actually have it minus
in that game four
david and you can analyze for us that
would be great i mean we had this moment
in game three
and um you talked about not trusting
your intuition were you looking at
some moves here yeah i mean
my first reaction was what
he can't take with the queen on d4 uh
this can't be it and he also did it very
quickly
and i started calculating
all of these things but i somehow missed
uh this bishop g2 move there so
yeah i don't know um so a position like
this for example where
if white defends just bishop g2 at the
end and yeah
and and that just makes coming um
yeah this was one thing but i feel like
this was more of an
accidental chance even though i mean i
could feel that
um that there there there might be
something there
um but i think earlier on when
when you play bishop b3 uh i mean i
really need to take an h3
um that's that's what i feel uh
regardless of
whether whether it it works it just
um it just and here yeah
instead of taking on h3 apparently a4 is
extremely strong
okay this is obvious right but
but the thing is like this is
throwing a in a4 this is not
a novel or particularly difficult
idea um if you start
looking for for things there
and obviously i was spending my time
looking at bishop h3
and i was calculating all these all of
these lines but i couldn't
couldn't completely make it work but
with with a4
everything everything just works and i
feel like here especially down in the
match
i should have i should have gone for um
i should have gone for this uh because
even even other other lines there
um are not bad for me at all
i think a4 is probably very good but
also other lines
are not bad um because of one
very very simple thing that i missed uh
let me just show you like bishop
queen h3 for instance
uh yeah take on f4 and
knight f4 uh knight e3 let's say rook 8
v8
and the thing is here i was thinking
knight g5
um but then queen h6
and here i thought queen g4 and i didn't
calculate further
uh which is a big mistake obviously
because i i just went on the spot so
yeah this wasn't very good um
and then i will just point you to one
moment in the last game as well
okay um at which point magnus uh
when he played a4 okay let me find this
it's fantastic too to hear how chess
players analyze and to learn notation
i'm i'm
keeping my close eye on this okay i
think i'm not um
yeah so the thing is here my intuition
was screaming that king age one wins
just screaming
and um
the thing is it wins and it's not very
difficult
king h1 a b rook g1
king h8
and here i was looking at all sorts of
queen e3's and all
and and all this but i couldn't yeah
queen e3 king h7 doesn't work
uh but the thing is i just needed to
consider e6
and that's just
gamer over on the spot so
uh yeah that that was really really
um that was really really bad as well
because um yeah this if i see king h1
i i think at least practically speaking
the game is just
just over because if he can't do
anything
immediately here um he's just dead like
he uh strategically he's
absolutely busted um
since yeah my my attack is just
unstoppable so that was um that was that
was really poor
and apparently i missed some chances
later on as well but then
it was becoming um was becoming
complicated
and um
but but yeah there were just uh a few
instances today of not following
my intuition which um which were
just frustrating and especially
considering the
the first game where i did go for a
sacrifice
which didn't work at all um
yeah because i just missed the the
sequence that it that he had so
overall overall no shame in losing
losing to him but i just feel that i
could have done
a whole lot better with the chance that
i had today
and yeah that's um
it's not gonna this that's gonna sit
well tonight i think well but i'm
wondering magnus but
because you you sort of after uh the
quarterfinals with the neil duval
you were annoyed with your playing you
applauded maxim after the semifinals and
then
a little bit annoyed again here with
your intuition so are you sort of your
own biggest opponent these days is that
where you're not getting
you know that final uh finesse to to win
these tournaments that we usually see
you winning
uh yeah for sure um
it's clear uh
by the play today and also some other
days that
while there are some definitely some
good things to my my play
um yeah i don't trust myself
um fully and um
yeah this this shows in uh in critical
critical moments and um
yeah it's hard to say what exactly i can
i can do about it
at the moment but um
so yeah i mean wesley is very strong but
as as you could see today he's also
extremely uh extremely beatable um you
have about a month now until the next
meltdown champions chess store which is
the magnus carlsen invitational
what is your plan now uh before that
will you take some polls from chess will
you have like training camp will you
play tournaments what will you do
i'll definitely try to get some new
ideas for
for the next tournament at the very
least uh
i definitely um to need need to to
to freshen up even more i feel like i
tried that in the preliminaries um
but um didn't didn't quite quite work
out in the in the knockout so
yeah that is one thing and just to try
and
in general build up uh um
build up uh physical physically uh
try and get some energy and and so on so
i don't i don't think um
yeah i don't think i particularly uh
need
like um massive break or anything like
i i don't feel as nearly as dissolution
does
after the last few few tournaments
well that's very good to hear magnus and
we thank you for a great show in this
tournament looking forward to
the next one thank you for joining us
yeah thank you and if i didn't mention
before obviously congrats to to wesley
um i mean regardless of
what chances i had to today um
i didn't take them and
[Music]
in the tournament as a whole uh he he
was better so he deserved to win
very good thank you magnus thank you